I want to talk to you today about what I
think is a relatively way new way of
looking at your experience but maybe
even more broadly than that a new way of
looking at reality itself you all come
my two University I suppose to make your
conceptions of reality more
sophisticated and you want to do that
because you have to live in the world
and the more sophisticated your
conceptions the less likely you'll
encounter tragic or harmful
circumstances that you will be unable to
deal with it really matters if you know
what you're thinking and you know how to
think over the last twenty years I would
say there's been a revolution in
psychology and the revolution has
involved the transformation in the way
that we look at the world and that's
what I want to talk to you about today I
entitled this talk reality and the
sacred it's a strange title for a talk
to modern people because we don't really
understand what the sacred means unless
we live within a worldview that's
essentially I wouldn't say archaic but
at least traditional for modern free
thinking fundamentally liberal people
the idea the sacred is anachronistic or
if not anachronism comprehensible so I
want to start with a story from the Old
Testament there's a scene in the Old
Testament when the ancient Hebrews are
moving the Ark of the Covenant and the
Ark of the Covenant is a device that was
manufactured in order to contain the
Word of God and there was a rule among
the ancient Hebrews which was you were
not to touch the Ark of the Covenant no
matter what and there's a story in the
Old Testament where the bearers of the
Ark of the Covenant they used to carry
it the bearers of the Ark of the
Covenant trip and a man reaches out to
steady it and when he touches it God
strikes him dead and modern people look
at a story like that and the first thing
they think is that seems a little bit
harsh on the part of God given that the
man was attempting to do something that
he believed was good
but what the story is designed to
indicate in my opinion is that there are
certain things that you touch at your
peril regardless of your intentions and
those things that you touch at your
peril regardless of your intentions most
cultures regard as sacred as untouchable
I want to make a case for you today that
those things exist and also why they
exist and why it's necessary for you to
know that they exist I would also say
that if you're properly educated in the
university especially with regards to
the humanities which are in some
conceptual trouble at the moment what
you are what essentially happens to you
is that you're introduced in a
relatively secular way to the concept of
the sacred you're here in the university
to learn about the eternal values of
humankind and I think that people who
tell you that those values do not exist
or that they're endlessly debatable do
you an unbelievable disservice now I'm
gonna tell you first how you think about
the world I think so this would be a
Newtonian view of the world its
Newtonian and deterministic and it's a
worldview that dominated psychology and
economics and anthropology and political
science you name it for probably 400
years but it's coming to a crashing halt
in the last 50 years and the consequence
of that consequences of that have been
manifested in a number of domains the
old world presuppositions are something
like this the world is made out of
objects when you look at the world you
see the objects there they are in front
of you as a consequence of seeing the
objects you think about what to do and
after you think about what to do in
presence of the objects you act now that
seems self-evident because when you look
at the world
they're the objects are and it appears
to you that you see them and then you
think about them and then you act but
there's a real problem with that first
problem is use half your brain to see
literally human visual cortex
very large part of your brain and the
reason that the visual cortex is so
large is that seeing is as far as we can
tell actually impossible now the fact
that seeing perception is impossible
wasn't discovered by psychologists and
it wasn't discovered by philosophers it
was discovered by people who working who
were working on artificial intelligence
and trying to make artificially
intelligent machines the presupposition
of the people who were making
intelligent machines was the hard part
of interacting with the world is
figuring out what to do once you see the
objects but it turned out that making
machines that could see objects was
impossible and the reason for that is
that boundaries between objects are not
obvious they're not obvious at all in
fact it's very difficult to understand
how it is that we separate things up at
all now let me give you an example and
so if you think about yourself when you
look in the mirror you see yourself as
an object you see your eyes you see your
nose you see your face you see your body
and that's pretty much what you see when
you look at other people but that isn't
all there is to you in fact that's
hardly any of what there is to you so
you could say for example you exist at
the level of the quantum particle you
can't perceive that in fact people
didn't know that until 75 years ago
above that level you exist at an atomic
level and then a molecular level and
then you exist at the level of complex
organs and then the interactions between
those organs and then you and then your
family and then the groups that your
family belong to and then the ecosystem
that the groups of your are that that
all your groups belong to and on and so
on
so on and so forth until what it is that
you are can expand to encompass
virtually anything now when you look at
yourself you don't see that you see
yourself at a certain level of
resolution when you look at the world
you see yourself at a certain level of
resolution but all those other levels
are equally real and equally relevant
and we in fact have very little idea how
it is that you're only able to see what
you see almost nothing has obvious
boundaries and this has real-world
consequences it's not something that's
merely abstract
the technical term for this problem in a
problem of how to bind your perceptions
to limit them is called the frame
problem the frame problem was discovered
about 40 years ago and the philosopher
Daniel Dennett called it the most
important philosophical discussion
discovery of the last 50 years the frame
problem emerges to cause all sorts of
trouble for people so for example when
Henry Ford invented the automobile
well at least invented the modern
procedure of building the automobile
what Ford presumed was that he was
building an efficient means of
transporting people from one place to
the other
there were other unintended consequences
of Ford's discovery so for example Ford
happened to be a great supporter of
fascism and the reason that he was a
supporter of fascism bit was because he
regarded the fashion fascist political
structure as a logical extension of the
efficient methods that he'd used to
assemble vehicles so his mode of
production was instantly manifested in a
political philosophy furthermore now
2009 a hundred years after the invention
of the automobile we've discovered some
other things that the car was other than
a place to move people from point A to
point B so for example it turns out that
the automobile and the internal
combustion engine
are among the most effective
technologies ever devised to transform
the nature of the atmosphere and to heat
up the world not only that the car is
completely transformed the nature of
cities and these were all unintended
consequences of the fact that the car
was far more than what people thought it
was and you can say that about any
technological structure no one knew what
T V would do to the news for example no
one knew what the internet would do to
the music industry everything that you
interact with is far more complicated
than you see the most ancient ideas we
have about the nature of reality make
are predicated on a certain
presupposition and the presupposition is
this there's two fundamental modes of
being that characterize reality one is
the absolute and absolute is the sum
total of everything
so if you think about things in their
most unbounded possible form if you
think of things in their infinite number
of potential variations you can think
about that as one pole of reality
it appears classically that people have
regarded their encounters with the
absolute which is all those multiple
levels of being that are beyond your
perceptual capacity as equivalent to an
encounter with God now you know that in
the Islamic religion it's against the
rules to make a graven image of any sort
of Muhammad right the idea is that
you're not supposed to make an image and
among the ancient Hebrews the idea was
very similar the Taoist say that you
shouldn't confuse the moon with a finger
pointing to the moon and what all that
means is that the absolute is always
something that transcends the finite
frame that you place around your
perceptions so as soon as you start
talking about it representing it making
statues of it or idolizing it you lose
your connection with the absolute
because you've turned it into something
that's understandable in concrete part
of the wisdom traditions that the world
still maintains make the constant moral
presupposition that you should always be
aware of what it is that transcends both
your understanding and your perceptions
and you should keep firmly in mind that
that exists now when people talk about
God in the modern world they tend to
think about something that's more that
more has more of the characteristics of
a being and I suppose that's where most
of the debate about religious reality
comes in but the idea that there's an
absolute that's outside of your
perceptual capacity seems to me to be
merely a statement of fact especially
given what we know now about the nature
of perception that the phenomena always
transcends the manner in which you frame
it we've also come to understand that
not only does reality have multiple
levels of existence but in order to
perceive it you have to stand inside
multiple frames this is a picture of a
French city
it's a walled city now the walls are
there to keep the people in and the
walls are there to keep what isn't in
the walls out and so you can think about
that as a protective structure now I
want to tell you how
is that you still inhabit a walled city
and exactly what that means so for
example you think about this room tent
I'm going to tell you how it is that
this room allows you to see what it is
that you see now when you're interacting
with a computer you actually don't
interact with the computer you interact
with the keyboard on the screen if the
computer crashes then you interact with
the computer and you find that as a
general rule very annoying because you
don't really understand the computer
very well and you don't actually see how
complex it is until it stops working
most of the time when you're interacting
with the world you're doing things with
the world you're interacting with it in
a way that produces some consequence
that you want and that means in part
that your perceptions are always framed
by what you want and that's actually one
of the reason why the world isn't just
made out of objects the world is made
out of things you use and things that
get in your way now you're always
applying a frame like that to the world
in order to simplify it enough so that
you can understand it and you're aided
in this process by all sorts of
processes you really don't notice
because when you look at the world you
think well there are the objects but
there's a thousand things going on
before you make that judgment so we'll
look at this room when you walk in here
the room tells you what to do the reason
it tells you what to do is because all
the seats are pointed in the same
direction they're all slanted in a
particular way when you walk in here and
there's other people sitting you can see
that all their faces point to the front
people's faces point towards what
interests them the room is set up to
make you face the front the theory
behind the room is that the thing that's
interesting in the room is happening at
the front it's a theater what's
happening at the front is a drama right
because theater is there to promote and
and and undergird drama a lecture is a
dramatic act the room tells you what to
do so you don't have to think about what
to do when you come into a room like
this you can just do it because the room
tells you what to do and then you can
think you can sit in here in relative
comfort and listen to this lecture why
can you sit in here in relative comfort
do all the people around you have been
relatively carefully selected right as a
consequence of
analysis of their 12 years in school the
university has made a determination that
they know how to sit down and listen
that hypothetically there are
intelligent enough to understand the
lecture and that they're very unlikely
to disrupt the proceedings with any
unexpected outburst of emotion or
motivation now if anybody broke one of
those rules you can be sure that your
eyes would move very rapidly away from
me and directly towards the person who
is causing the trouble because that
would take center stage now this room is
actually supported by a million
invisible processes so for example while
you're sitting in here you don't have to
worry about whether it's raining because
there's a roof and you don't have to
worry about whether the roof is going to
fall in because you make the presumption
that the people who built the roof are
competent and the electricity works
because the electricity's the utility is
run by people who are competent so it's
almost always on buildings hardly ever
burned down the electricity hardly ever
fluctuates there's thousands of people
out there working as hard as they can
diligently to make this environment
constant enough so that you can ignore
all the thousands of things that you're
ignoring so you can concentrate well
enough to attend to the few things that
you are attending to while you're in
this room you're in a walled city
there's multiple walls and those walls
protect you from what's outside the
walls you can think about it this way
this is a Taoist image of reality now
people think about this as a
metaphysical symbol but it's not a
metaphysical symbol it's an unbelievably
practical symbol the Daoists believe
that the world the reality is made up
essentially of chaos and order chaos is
all those things you don't understand so
I would say that chaos is all those
things that exist outside of your
perceptual preconditions order is all
the things you do understand and all the
places you go where the things that you
do produce the results that you intend
and the Daoists would say everywhere you
go is like that everywhere you go has
things that you understand that are
orderly and has things that you don't
understand that are chaotic and the
chaotic things attract your attention
because you already understand the
orderly things
if something unexpected happens your
nervous system automatically reacts to
ignore emc towards it and sometimes that
could be catastrophic so this is an
experience that some of you will have in
the next four years undoubtedly there's
a number of you that want to go to
medical school or to graduate school or
to law school or to business school and
a certain percentage of you will take
the admission tests that will determine
whether or not you're able to take that
path and a certain percentage of you
will score below the 50th percentile on
those tests and that will mean you will
not be going to those institutions and
when that happens first of all you'll
shake and tremble when you open the
envelope to find out your results and
second if you haven't achieved the score
that you expected that you will achieve
your world will fall apart and what
that'll mean is that you descend from
the domain of order into the domain of
chaos and that happens to people all the
time it happens to people when they
develop an illness that's serious that
they can't control because then their
body stops becoming something they can
predict and starts to become something
that they can't predict it happens to
people with they're in an intimate
relationship and they're betrayed they
assume fidelity and the person tells
them that they've had an affair that's
chaos that means you didn't know who
that person was the future you imagine
no longer exists your perceptions of
people are erroneous at some level of
analysis that you don't understand it's
conceivable that you're naive beyond
belief and that everything you believed
about yourself and other people up to
that point is false and when a
revelation occurs that knocks out one of
the walls that supports you and you
descend accidentally into chaos you'll
regard that as one of the worst
experiences of your life when that
happens to you your brain knows exactly
what to do it stops thinking about the
future
it stopped saving up resources for the
future it puts you in emergency
preparation mode so you're ready to do
anything at the drop of a hat because
you don't know what to do so your body
prepares to do everything it shifts your
cortisol levels up it activates your
left and right cortices your limbic
system and your motivational systems are
disinhibited turned on and you sweat and
you can't sleep because
the orderly structure that you thought
you inhabited that provided you with
security and direction has now
disappeared and the Daoists believe that
the world is always an interplay between
chaos and order and that if you live
your life properly you stand with one
foot in order and one foot in chaos
because if you're only in order nothing
that's interesting ever happens to you
nothing is anything but a repeat of all
of all the things that you already know
that's the state that fascists desire
because fascists desire things to be
exactly the way they are forever
and if you're in a state that's only
characterized by chaos you're at sea or
overwhelmed or things have fallen apart
for you and there's too much of
everything for you to deal with now the
Daoist being very wise people know other
things as well but they know for example
that chaos can turn into order that's
why there's a white dot in the middle of
the black Paisley and they know that
order can turn into chaos which is why
there's a black dot in the middle of the
white paisley and the Daoists believe
that a meaningful life the optimally
meaningful life is to be found on the
border between chaos and order and I
would say that your nervous system tells
you exactly when you are there and it's
a kind of place and you can tell when
you're there because you're secure
enough to be confident but not so secure
that you're bored and you're interested
enough to be awake but not so interested
that you're terrified and when you're in
a state like that when you find things
interesting and meaningful time slips by
you and you're no longer self-conscious
there's a medieval Christian
representation of the nature of reality
on the outside you have the Virgin Mary
inside the Virgin Mary you have God the
Father and God the Father is supporting
a crucifix with an individual on it the
individual and Christian thinking is
Christ what does this image mean
the walled city divides order from chaos
or order from nature we think about
nature as the thing that's outside of
what we understand that's mother nature
mother nature gives birth to all things
that's the idea that's expressed in this
image so the Virgin Mary is standing for
mother nature out of mother nature
arises order and tradition that's true
for primates is like chimpanzees as much
as it's true for us any social animals
that are grouped together have to form
an orderly structure that they can habit
together that defines their boundaries
and their goals because otherwise they
fight each other to the death so in the
state of untrammeled nature as Hobbes
pointed out it's every man for himself
and without the order that tradition
brings
there's nothing but chaos and chaos is
murderous and unproductive there's a
problem with order if you look at the
history of the 20th century it's a
toss-up whether mother nature is being
harder on us or whether our governmental
traditions have being harder on us you
know of course that the dictatorship of
Hitler killed six million Jews 120
million people in the Second World War
you may not know that the Stalinist
dictatorships in the Soviet Union killed
an estimated 60 million people in
internal repression not counting those
people who died in the Second World War
and the internal repression that
characterized Mao's Communist China
killed a hundred million people and so
the problem with tradition is that
sometimes it's a wise king and sometimes
it's a king that eats its own sons which
means that although we need tradition to
guide us and to structure even the
manner in which we perceive the world
our traditions can become archaic and
outdated and cruel and inhuman and as a
consequence they can pose a worse threat
to us than chaos itself nature or chaos
is exactly the same dichotomous
structure the figure on the left is a
Medusa or a Gorgon if you look at the
Medusa as you probably already know you
turn to stone
the reason you turn to stone is because
when you look upon nature or chaos
without your normal veils it paralyzes
you physiologically just like a prey
animal like a rabbit is terrified if it
sees a wolf for millions of years human
beings were prey animals we were
probably prey animals for large reptiles
which accounts for example for the
reason that it appears that primates
like us are naturally afraid of
predatory reptiles if you're in the
presence of something that violates your
assumptions of safety you'll freeze you
freeze so that the thing that might eat
you can't see you and that's what turns
you to stone
that's nature and it's terrible aspect
and the terrible aspect of nature can
freeze everyone and you can be sure and
will be seldom taught that you will
encounter that at some point in your
life
the primary Buddhist dictum is that life
is suffering and what does that mean it
means that because you're finite and
you're surrounded by something that's
absolute in a sense you're in a battle
that you can never win because there's
always more of what it is that you're
trying to contend with then there is
with you and worse than that and it's
for this reason that tyrannies can't
last is that the thing that you're
contending with isn't even static it
keeps changing so that what worked for
you yesterday won't necessarily work for
you tomorrow this is an L chemical
version of the taoist yin and yang
symbol and basically it says something
that's more sophisticated and complex it
says that the world is made up of chaos
and order things that you can predict
and understand and things that you can't
predict and can't understand and inside
the order there's some chaos and inside
that chaos there's some order and inside
that order there's some chaos and so on
and so forth and equally the case for
order
you have Mother Nature representation of
chaos sometimes positive sometimes
negative you have a representation of
the Great Father that's security and
tyranny to things you'll always have to
contend with and finally in this
representation you have a representation
of the individual at least a Christian
representation of the individual and
that's Christ and it's a terrifying
representation it's a remarkable
representation because it's not a
representation of transcendence it's a
representation of suffering and it's a
funny kind of representation of
suffering because the manner in which
the story unfolds is this Christ as the
archetypal individual the model for
individuals from a psychological or
mythological perspective knows that he's
limited and knows that he's doomed to
both suffering and death in the Garden
of Gethsemane the night before his
crucifixion he has an argument with God
and the argument basically is do I
actually have to do this and the answer
is twofold well no actually you don't
have to accept your suffering but you
don't have to voluntarily accept your
suffering but there are consequences if
you don't
now the Christian story is predicated on
the idea that if you voluntarily accept
your suffering you can simultaneously
transcend it it's a remarkable
philosophy and it's also something that
we have very good support for from a
psychological perspective so for example
if I'm treating someone who has an
anxiety disorder panic disorder who
can't go out of their house without
their heart rate elevating and without
collapsing into a panic-stricken heap
without visiting the emergency ward
every time their heart rate accelerates
every time they're in a subway every
time they're in a mall so they're so
terrified of existence they can't even
get out of their house the way you cure
that person is by getting them to
voluntarily approach the things that
they're afraid of and it turns out that
physiologically if I force you to accept
a certain kind of challenge your body
will go into emergency preparation mode
and you'll become stressed and that
stress will cause you physiological
damage including brain damage if it's
sustained for long enough but if I
present you with the same challenge and
you accept it voluntarily your brain
doesn't produce stress hormones and
completely different physiological
systems kick in and what that means is
people have evolved two modes for
dealing with the unknown one is
voluntary approach and the other is
panic-stricken paralysis and flight in
this representation you can see that
there are crowds of people standing in
the wings of the open statue looking at
the Crucified individual it's a very
strange thing but you know you still see
this you still see people doing things
like this that they don't notice I went
to a museum in New York and there were a
very large number of paintings there
from the late Renaissance and they were
all religiously themed like medieval
paintings except they they featured
recognizable individuals and people had
come from all over the world to look at
those paintings there are extremely
valuable paintings you know they were
painted by Michelangelo or Leonardo da
Vinci and each of them was probably
valued for reasons that are very
difficult to understand at something
approximating hundreds of millions of
dollars the late Renaissance was the
first time in human history where human
beings dared to presume that sacred
images could be given an individual
human face and that idea was actually
what launched the Enlightenment and
launched the development of modern
culture the late Renaissance thinkers
the artists in particular were the first
people deposit that there was some
direct relationship between these sacred
images and actual people and people come
from all over the world to look at these
paintings even though they don't
understand what they mean I want to show
you some images that describe how the
idea of the suffering individual
developed and what that means the first
thing I want to show you is this picture
of Saint George and the dragon now you
know the main street that runs through
the university is named after Saint
George right this is a very old image
the oldest story we know which is a
Mesopotamian creation myth features a
God who confronts a reptilian monster
and makes the world as a consequence of
the conflict he faces her she's
terrifying he cuts her up into pieces
and out of the pieces he makes the world
now the Mesopotamians 5,000 years ago
we're trying to figure out what the
nature of individuality was and what the
nature of consciousness was and their
presupposition which was dramatized
because these people told stories they
didn't think the way we think in in in
an explicit philosophical logical meet
with philosophical processes they
thought in stories which is a natural
way for people to think they came to the
conclusion that the object of their
ultimate worship was the God who
confronted the dragon of chaos cut it
into pieces and made the world and that
idea has echoed down through the ages
it's an idea that human beings have
never lost now this idea is very
interesting so you see the castle in the
background and we already know what the
castle stands for the castle stands for
order and it's a multi walled castle
because everyone's protected by multiple
walls but those walls are constantly
breached now young people especially
modern young people are often very
cynical about the traditions that they
inhabit they're cynical about them
because they see the fact that the world
is theoretically devolving into some
kind of environmental catastrophe and
their cynical because they're still worn
because they're still hunger their
cynical because often the people who are
teaching them the traditions don't seem
to believe in them themselves it's very
easy for young people to look at the
traditions that were and to notice the
breaks but the truth of the matter is is
that throughout human history tradition
has always been anachronistic and
out-of-date and what you see in images
of st. George and the dragon is that the
Dragons always breach the walls which
means that tradition is always under
attack from chaos well of course it is
because the future is different than the
past but that doesn't mean that the past
should be abandoned because if you
abandon the past and you knock down all
your walls you fall into a pit of chaos
and not classically speaking is
indistinguishably indistinguishable from
hell and I can tell you that if you
spend long enough in that state you'll
become bitter and cruel because that's
what happens to people who suffer
endlessly say George is a different kind
of individual when the walls come
crumbling down as they always do he
decides to go out and to confront the
dragon now dragons are very strange
creatures as you may have already noted
first of all they don't exist
second of all they have very weird
propensity so for example they
golde and they tend to trap virgins in
their lair which you will also admit as
very strange behavior for a reptile now
the idea behind this is that's very very
complicated idea it's all presented
pictorially the idea is that the thing
that lurks underneath if you look to the
right of the picture you can see that
there's a cave the cave goes way down
into the ground and way down into the
ground is the terrifying place that's
underneath everything the dragon curls
out from time to time to threaten the
structure of everything that's known st.
George comes out to confront the dragon
voluntarily overcomes it and in this
image rescues the Virgin that the dragon
has been guarding it's a very
complicated story it means that the
things that terrify you contain things
of value that's also what the image of
the goal that the dragon horse
represents it means something else as
well it means that the individual man
who's likely to go out and confront
chaos when tradition is crumbling is
more likely to find a mate this is Jonah
Jonah had a very weird experience he was
swallowed by a whale that's a very
strange whale as you as you might well
note it's a medieval whale and of course
medieval people didn't really know what
whale's word so they were guessing what
a way it was and so a whale for a
medieval person would have been a big
fish would have been a squid that would
have been some monstrous thing like a
shark that lurks in the deep because
they didn't happy they weren't able to
segregate all those things out
biologically there their powers of
collective observation weren't that good
so the whale for them was what lurks
underneath in the darkness right and the
idea with Jonah was that now and then
what lurks underneath and the darkness
rises up to swallow you but if your
attitude is proper then you can come
back out the other side changed now
that's a story of redemption so for
example imagine that you are a were in a
bad relationship and maybe you weren't
that happy about it but you know it was
better than no relationship at all and
then the person that you're in a
relationship betrayed you and they
they did that because you actually
weren't that happy with the relationship
anyways maybe they did that because
you're a little bit naive or maybe they
did that because you're a little bit too
easy to get along with and as a
consequence I'd and so when they first
leave you it's a catastrophe because
your world falls apart but when your
world falls apart you're somewhere new
as possible to learn something new in
that place so you might learn for
example that you should be a little
sharper the next time that you go out
with someone or you should be a little
bit more careful about picking up on
clues that your partner's bored with you
or that maybe you should stop
associating with lying Psychopaths and
your life would be a lot more positive
and stop thinking that you have the
capacity to redeem somebody that is not
after redemption in the least and what
that means now and then is that when you
fall into the belly of a whale and
you're swallowed up by something that
lurks underneath that you can come out
the other side transformed and that's
actually how people learn every time you
learn something you learn because
something you did didn't work and that
exposes you to the part of the world
that you don't understand every time
you're exposed to a part of the world
that you don't understand you have the
possibility of rebuilding the structures
that you use to interpret the world
that's often why it's more important to
notice that you're wrong than it is to
prove that you're right one of the
things that you're supposed to learn in
university is precisely that it might be
useful to listen to people that annoy
you on the off chance that they know
something that if they tell you you can
use instead of dying talking to people
who agree with what you say is like
walking around in a desert you already
know everything that they say the reason
you're associating with them in that
situation is so that they never say
anything that challenges you because
you're afraid that if you go outside of
what you understand that you won't be
able to tolerate the chaos but it isn't
the case people have an unbelievable
capacity to face and overcome things
they don't understand and not only that
that's essentially what gives life its
meaning the Buddhists say life is
suffering and you think well if that's
the case why bother with it and people
do ask that question and they ask it in
ways that result in their own
destruction and worse in the destruction
of others
so for example people who become
particularly cruel particularly in a
genocidal manner are more than willing
to dispense with as many human beings as
that they can possibly train their
sights on because they're so disgusted
by the nature of human limitation that
they'd rather eradicate it and lots of
people become suicidal because they
can't bear the conditions of their own
existence and suffering is real and it's
inescapable so the question is what do
you do about it
you notice in your own life and you can
do this by watching your own life I
often ask my clients to do this say look
watch your life for a week and pretend
you don't know who you are because you
don't know who you are at all what you
understand most about yourself are the
arbitrary presuppositions that you use
to hem yourself in and you act as if
those presuppositions are true so that
the revelation of the full nature of
your character won't terrify you people
hide in their own boxes and it's not
surprising but it's not a good idea
because life is too hard to hide in a
box you can't manage it if you do that
if you watch yourself for a week you'll
see certain things you'll see some of
the time that you're resentful and
annoyed and those are times when you're
either taking advantage of yourself or
you're thinking improperly some of the
time you'll be bored in which case
you're either undisciplined or you're
probably pursuing something you don't
want to pursue and some of the time
you'll actually be engaged in life and
the times that you're engaged in life
you won't notice that you're there right
there just a distinction between subject
and object disappears when you're
engaged in something that you find
meaningful the purpose of life as far as
I can tell from studying mythology and
from studying psychology for decades is
to find a mode of being that's so
meaningful that the fact that life is
suffering is no longer relevant
or maybe that it's even acceptable and I
would say as well that people know when
they're doing that you know when you're
doing that in part because you're no
longer resentful you think geez I could
do this forever
right there's a timelessness
timelessness that's associated with that
state of being from a mythological
perspective that's equivalent to brief
habitation of the kingdom of God that's
the place where you are that's so
meaningful
it enables you to bear the harsh
preconditions of life without becoming
resentful bitter or cruel and there's
nothing that you can pursue in your life
that will be half as useful as that your
nervous system being an evolved
structure is evolved for a universe that
is composed of the interaction between
chaos and order those are the most
fundamental constants that we know they
transcend the mere perception of objects
everywhere you go is chaos and order
traditional Chinese doctors go into
people's houses to diagnose why it is
that someone in that house is suffering
and they walk in and they think there's
too much order here
I've been in houses like that that's a
house where all the furniture is covered
with plastic that's a house where if you
put a glass on a wooden table the
mistress of the house runs over with the
coaster slips it under immediately and
gives you a dirty look that's a place
where the children never play in the
living room that's a place where the
lines in the carpet are vacuumed so
precisely that they're actually parallel
that's a place where there's so much
order that no one can survive because
the person who runs the house is a
tyrant and that anyone who's sick in
that house is sick because they're
suffering from an excess of order and
then you can walk into a house that's
completely different and you can even
see this in your own room if you want
everything's in complete disarray you
can't even look at that place you're
sick the moment you cross the threshold
because everywhere you look there's
parts of untransformed chaos yelling to
you do something about this loser if you
walk into your study and you have a
stack of papers in the midst of which is
buried your homework you'll notice that
you have a very tough time looking at
that stack of papers and the reason for
that is that the stack of papers that
you're ignoring that's aging and causing
you more trouble with each passing day
is a portal into order through which
chaos is flowing and if you ignore that
long enough the chaos will flow through
that portal and take over your room and
then take over your life
and you might think well that's a very
strange way of looking at things and I
suppose it is but just as an experiment
to see whether or not this is true
try not paying your taxes for ten years
and see what happens this is an old
representation right Atlas with the
world well it's a representation that
says that that's the proper way to live
right that the way that you live
properly so that you can withstand the
nature of your own being is to pick up a
load that's heavy enough so that if you
carry it you have some self-respect
that's a very weird idea because it's
frequently the case that people do
everything they can to lighten their
load but the problem with carrying a
light load is that then you have nothing
that's useful to do and if you have
nothing useful to do all you have around
you unless you're extremely fortunate if
not will only be the case for very short
periods of time is meaningless suffering
and there's nothing worse for your soul
than meaningless suffering if you look
around you see the people that you
respect and I don't mean that you think
about respecting I mean the ones that
you're got to your whole being your
embodied being tells you to respect
you'll see that it's always people who
picked up something heavy and are
carrying it successfully you think now
that's what it means to be a human being
and when you see that you can think well
perhaps life is worthwhile despite the
fact that the essential nature of
reality is suffering there's an old
Jewish idea and the idea is that man and
God are in the sense twins it's a very
strange idea but it seems to hinge on
something like this that classic
attributes of God these are the
attributes of the absolute are
omniscience omnipotence and omnipresence
do anything be anything can't translate
the other one momentarily there's a
question that goes along with that what
is a being that's characterized by the
absolute attributes of God Locke and the
answer that is limitation and that's an
unbelievably interesting idea and the
reason it's so interesting is because
one of the things that modern psychology
is increasingly telling us is that
without the limitation that a creature
like us with the structure of our
consciousness brings to bear on the
world there's no reality that what
reality is is an emergent consequence of
the interaction between something that's
painfully limited like us and whatever
the absolute is which is something that
is completely without borders and what
that implies in a sense is that without
limitation there's no being with
limitation they're suffering without
suffering them there's no being well you
might think well perhaps there should be
no beating and lots of people act their
whole lives in order to see if they can
make that a possibility and that's
really a luxury we don't have anymore
but the alternative is to presume that
being is worth the suffering and to find
a mode of being that allows you to make
that claim in reality and I would say in
a sense that's your existential destiny
and if you're here at university rather
than a trade school your job is to
figure out how to be a human being and
that's a much more important job than
any specific time limited concrete
permit pragmatic plan you have an
unlimited possibility for good
really individuals are way more powerful
than they think they're more powerful
for evil but they're also more powerful
for good these archaic stories that I've
been telling you about they have
something to say to you
they say life is uncertain you'll never
know enough and not only that you never
can knew enough and not only that
everything that you stand on is shaky
and then they say but you still have to
stand on it and while you're standing on
it you have to improve it and that's how
life goes on and that's how you live
your life and if you forget those things
or if you undermine them you're in the
same situation that the unfortunate man
was that I told you about in the Old
Testament who reached out to touch
something he should have left alone to
the degree that you're human you have to
abide by a certain set of truths the
truths that I told you about today are
as far as I can tell something that's
close to a minimal set there's chaos
there's order you're stuck with both of
them and they both have a cost
and they both have advantages and your
job is to figure out how to serve as the
appropriate mediator between the two and
you can tell when you're doing that
because when you're doing that the
dismal circumstances of your life
manifest themselves to you as eminently
acceptable and it's in that situation
that you know that you've placed
yourself in a position in nature where
everything is in harmony and that's the
place to aim for nice talking to you
[Applause]
the first thing I would say is that if
you're dealing with someone who's
depressed and they're really depressed
you should try giving them
antidepressants because if they die you
can't help them okay so if you're
suffering you are obligated in a sense
to hold on to whatever rope someone
throws you and one of the things I do
with my clients all the time especially
if they're really in trouble is to tell
them look I don't know exactly what's
gonna have helped you but don't
arbitrarily throw out any possibilities
because you might not have that luxury
antidepressants help a lot of people and
there are technical reasons why that's
the case
so that's a simple answer it's not
relevant to what I already described
except that if you're offered a gift by
your society and it works try it I don't
care what your presuppositions are apart
from that lots of the lots of time lots
of the time you see people who are
suffering with depression for example
there's a multitude of reasons but I'll
take one common reason you can think
about it as associated with the story of
Peter Pan a Peter Pan is someone who
won't grow up right now the problem with
Peter Pan is he gets to be king but it's
king of neverland neverland doesn't
exist
so being king of nothing isn't that
helpful well one of the things that you
often see with people who suffer from
depression and and I'm not making a
blanket statement about the cause of
depression because there's lots of them
is that people who don't have enough
order in their life tend to get
overwhelmed so for example if someone
comes in to me and sees to see me and
they say they're depressed I always ask
them a very standard set of questions I
do have a job if you don't have a job
you're really in trouble in our society
first of all you your biological rhythms
tend to go off the rails right away
because there's no reason to go to bed
at any particular time and there's no
reason to get up and for many people if
they don't get up at the same time they
follow up the functioning of their
circadian rhythms and that's enough to
make them depressed right off the bat
especially if they start napping during
the afternoon they don't also don't have
a purpose people aren't good without a
purpose and this isn't this isn't
hypothesizing we absolutely understand
the circuitry that underlies positive
emotion we know how it works almost all
the positive emotion that any of you are
likely to experience in your life
will not be a consequence of attaining
things it will be a consequence of
seeing that things are working as you
proceed towards a goal you value that's
completely different and you need to
know this because people are often
stunned for example they finish their
PhD thesis and their presupposition is
that they're going to be elated for a
month and often instead they're actually
depressed and they think what the hell
I've been working on this for seven
years and I handed it in and what do I
do now and that's what depresses them
right it's the what do I do now well
they're fine if they enjoyed it
pursuing the thing as long as it was
working out they get a lot of enthusiasm
and excitement over that because that's
how our nervous systems work most of
your positive emotion is dual pursuit
emotion if you take drugs like cocaine
or amphetamine the reason they're
enjoyable is because they turn on the
systems that help you pursue goals
that's why people like them so if you
don't have a job you got no structure
that's not good
plus you tend not to have a point so
you're overwhelmed by chaotic lack of
structure and you don't have any
positive emotion well you have any
friends so sometimes you see people who
are depressed they have no job they have
no friends
they have no intimate relationship they
have an additional health problem and
they have a drug and alcohol problem my
experience has been if you have three of
those problems it's almost impossible to
help you you're so deeply mired in chaos
that you can't get out because you make
progress on one front and one of the
other problems pulls you down so one of
the things I tell people who are
depressed is like don't sacrifice your
stability get a job even if it's not the
job you exactly want get a damn job you
need a job
find some friends get out in the dating
circuit see if you can establish an
intimate relationship put together some
of the foundational items that that are
like pillars that your life rests on
well that's the practical thing to do so
that's one example with regards to
depression
well the thing is you don't just launch
it on them you know you you've got to
negotiate with the person and you also
got to teach them to negotiate with
themselves and this is something that's
very useful to know you know you can't
Eren eyes yourself into doing things but
I wouldn't recommend it what I would
recommend instead is that you ask
yourself what you're willing to do it's
a really effective technique it's like a
meditative technique so for example you
can get up in the morning and you can
think well you know I'd like to have a
good day today so I'd like to go to bed
tonight without feeling guilty because I
you know didn't do some things I said I
was gonna do and I you know I'd like to
have kind of an interesting day so you
got to fulfill my responsibilities and I
want to you know enjoy the day then you
can ask yourself well okay what would I
have to do in order for that to happen
that I would do and the probability if
you practice this for three or four days
is your brain will just tell you it'll
say well you know there's that piece of
homework that you haven't done for like
three weeks you should knock that sucker
off because it would only take you ten
minutes and you've been avoiding it and
torturing yourself to death for you know
like like 72 hours straight and if you
do that here's a little interesting
thing you can do and you know maybe this
is a little obligations you should clean
up and so what what you do in a
situation like that is you teach the
person to negotiate with themself say
well let's figure out what your aims are
you got to have some aims whatever they
are and they might say well I'm so
depressed I don't have any aims and then
I say well pick the least objectionable
of the aims and act it out for a while
and see what happens because sometimes
your emotions your emotional systems are
so fouled up that you have to pretend
you have to act the thing out before you
can start to believe it I mean people
always assume they have to believe in
then out but but that's sometimes that's
true and lots of times it isn't so the
trick if you're doing therapeutic work
with someone and you're helping them
establish the structure is to find out
what they'll do now if they want to get
better which is not a given because
there are often payoffs for not getting
better that's basically the payoffs of
being a martyr or maybe the payoffs of
doing what you're entirely pathological
family members want you to do because
they actually want you to fail assuming
you want to get better there's usually
something you can figure out that would
constitute a step towards some sort of
concrete goal and my presumption it's a
behavior of presumptions fundamentally
is that small accruing gains that repeat
are unbelievably powerful so you know
this is another thing to know about in
your own life it's something I learned
in part from reading the writings of
Alexander Solzhenitsyn it was a great
Russian philosopher a novelist you know
we said you can look at your life and
you can see what isn't right about it I
mean all you have to do is look and then
you can start to fix that and the way
you fix it is by noticing what you could
in fact fix you know people are often
trying to fix things they can't fix
which I would not recommend because if
you try to fix something you can't fix
you'll just ruin it like you can find
all sorts of undergraduates who are
perfectly willing to restructure the you
know the international economic system
who cannot keep their room clean and
there's actually a gap there you know
which and it's surprising that people
don't actually notice so I would say if
you pay attention you can see things
that you could fix they yell at you
they really do we even know how that
happens let me let me give you an
example because rooms are full of
stories and the stories have have
effects on you so here's a classic
experiment so you take two groups
undergraduates you bring them into your
lab and you give one group on a
multiple-choice test that has a bunch of
words in it that are associated with
being old and you give the other group
the same multiple-choice test except the
words are associated with being young
this is independent of the content of
the test
it's just descriptions and then you time
the undergraduates as they walk back to
the elevators the ones who read the ones
who completed the multiple-choice test
that had more words associated with
aging walk slower back to the elevators
and they don't know that and they don't
know they're doing it and that that
studies been replicated in various forms
many many times you're unbelievably
sensitive to the story that your
environments telling you because your
environment is not made out of objects
that's just wrong your environment is
basically made out of something like
tools and obstacles you're a tool using
creature you're a tool perceiving
creature the things use like if I take
you out of this room and I said well
what was in the room you're not gonna
say you know random patterns in the
carpet because they're they're real just
as good an object as anything else
you're gonna say chairs because you can
sit on them and you're gonna say
handrails cuz you can hold them you can
say stairs because you can walk down
them that's what you see and that's what
you interact with and if you pay
attention to your environment which is
you by the way extended all of your
experiences you it will tell you all the
time what you should do
all you have to do is do it but then you
have to decide if you want to do it one
of the things I've noticed about people
because I've wondered once I started
studying these mythological stories and
I got this idea about the fact that life
can be meaningful enough to justify its
suffering I thought god that's such a
good idea because it's not optimistic
exactly you know some people tell you
what you can be happy it's like those
people are idiots I'm telling you
they're idiots there's gonna be things
that come along that flatten you so hard
you won't believe it
and you're not happy then and so if life
is to be happy well in those situations
what are you doing well I even live but
light isn't life isn't to be happy if
you're happy your bloody fortunate and
you should enjoy it you should because
it's the grace of God so to speak with
regards to to meaning I thought well
people know when they're doing something
meaningful they can tell so why the hell
don't they do meaningful things all the
time it seems obvious you could do it I
mean it's hard you know because other
people want you to do other things and
it's a struggle but everything's a
struggle and then I thought well oh I
get it I see why it took me about 10
years to figure this out people have a
choice choice number one nothing you do
means anything well that's kind of a
drag right meaninglessness of life and
all that existential angst you know
that's kind of a pain but the upside of
nothing that you do be mean is
meaningful is you don't have to do
anything
you've got no responsibility now you
have to suffer because things are
meaningless but that's a small price to
pay for being able to be completely
useless the alternative the alternative
is everything you do matters really if
you make a mistake it's a real mistake
if you betray someone you tilt the world
a little more sharply towards evil
rather than good it matters what you do
well if you buy that then you can have a
meaningful life but there's no mucking
around it means responsibility it means
that the decisions you make are
important it means that when you do
something wrong it's wrong well do you
want that
see that's a very hard question because
people don't always mean the same thing
when they say their own moral compass
now so in here here here's here's what I
mean by that technically part of the way
the reason that you're able to
distinguish between right and wrong is
because you are a certain kind of
biological organism and then another
reason is that your head is full of
other people let's write all the people
you've met all the people that you've
interacted with they're all telling you
a way to behave that's good in a way
that isn't there are circumstances under
which your conscience should fear the
duty you have to your conscience should
override the duty you have to social
norms but before you break a rule
because you think you're going to be
doing a good thing you bloody well
better make sure you have your head
screwed on straight because every time
you tell yourself a lie and every time
you act out a falsehood you disturb the
pristine integrity of your nervous
system and the reports it'll give you
about the nature of the world will be
distorted as a consequence of that so
yeah you have a moral obligation to
follow the dictates of your conscience
but you also have a moral obligation to
make sure that your life is straight
enough so that you can rely on your own
judgment and you can't separate those
things